oh yeah because you went to a place that
surfed like what was it like
award-winning like the beef Olympics
right so yeah so uh this I'm sure if you
watch Chris's video about it uh Japan
has the beef Olympics because of course
they do they do this with a lot of
produce actually yeah and every three or
four years they have every I don't know
how it works I assume every city brings
their beef to the table they judge which
one's the best and and Miyazaki the food
factor is one like the last 15 years
yeah to be fair it is and it's it's it
is it's so good right um and yeah we had
this course meal that was insane it was
just like it was a Nobel Prize so
there's Nobel Prize winners and this is
the meal they gave them and I was like
thank God Chris is paying the first dish
came out and it's [ __ ] caviar and I
was like thank God this isn't my video
I'm not paying for this holy [ __ ] I've
never had caviar before had it you had
never had cavities why the [ __ ] would I
eat caviar when would I have had it it
was [ __ ] like there must have been like
one [ __ ] and fats meal you've done
where they've just like added it in
added it yeah like a tiny amount no no
no no never had a million I had it and I
was like this is the most meh thing I'd
ever tasted yeah um I mean did you have
it by itself yeah oh well that's why
yeah it looks like it was all right it
was fine it just tasted like this tasted
like it shouldn't cost this much
actually okay so in Japan right they
don't have like the same uh what's the
word
uh hmm feelings
towards certain dishes and animals that
we have in the west right right right so
I went to this uh a friend of mine
invited me to a course meal and this
very very fancy restaurant all right
there's like a business meeting in Tokyo
in Tokyo right and I didn't know
anything about it I just knew that they
did like a really nice uh Fusion food or
something I don't know and um
there's a lot of weird foods that I've
never had uh I and there's a lot of
stuff that I haven't had because I've
heard it's awful and cruel like I've
never had whale have you think have you
had whale I've had it once yeah right
it's disgusting I've never gone out of
my way to get this stuff I'm sure you
didn't guard your way to get it either
it's just like obviously in Japan even
though the rest of the world is like we
will not whale Japan is like
No And there's a lot of places in
Hokkaido that openly sell whale stuff
and it's very normal right you know it's
a different cultural thing and is it
wrong it's for debate you know I think
it's it's kind of [ __ ] but it's
whatever it's my personal opinion it
doesn't matter it's not my country so
go to this restaurant and we're having
these courses and again I don't know
what's coming I can't read the menu
someone can't you dude I don't know
what's coming up but everything's been
good okay yeah everything has been
delicious and it's like to the point
where I'm like oh this is gonna cost too
much [ __ ] I'm gonna have to pay for this
yeah and it was just like a client thing
not when I climb someone's wanted to
take me to some meal and yeah
so sitting there and then the next meal
comes out and it's like it's like steak
and it's like oh it's so good and it's
like and then the next dish was it was
like a beef cheek in turtle soup and I
was like
I've never had Turtle before but I've
never had the but it wasn't the turtle I
wanted I was hoping for the extinct
Turtles
you wanted the tortoise yeah I wanted
the extinct Galapagos giant tortoise
unfortunately this was a common tortoise
so then I just felt sad yeah I thought
about like the Finding Nemo turtle and
alcohol
yeah yeah it was like a turtle sauce and
I felt like oh is this Turtle that's a
good thing how do I feel like eating
Turtle I didn't know how to but again
it's in front of me I didn't know what
it was and I was just like I just ate it
and then like oh that was Turtle I'm
like
apparently it's really good for your
libido
you know that's that's like every other
like that's everything like rare Asian
like ingredients it's totally common to
eat support yeah it's common in Asia but
not in the west try we don't need it at
all right
[Music]
securing for here I'm like Yay no let me
down right it's because common in soups
right in Japan soups and like uh yeah
and like nubbins yeah but that wasn't
the big boy
oh the next it gets weirder okay dude
and this is where I was like no why did
you bring this out what the guy brings
out next stop I felt so bad he brings
out he's like all right next dish we
have shark fin
oh no no
because I know because shark fin is very
cruel yeah right A lot of the times they
grab the shark they just pop the [ __ ]
finally throw it back and they can't
like swim properly so it just dies yeah
it's [ __ ] it's such a f like [ __ ] I
was like this is awful I didn't know if
I knew I was gonna get shocked I
wouldn't [ __ ] I wouldn't have agreed
to eat at this restaurant yeah I didn't
want to eat the shark so
we get the food and I'm like well I may
as well try it right because it's in
front of me have you ever had it no
never no this is your first time right
no way where the [ __ ] I don't even know
how to get shock in the UK If I wanted
to have it I don't think I don't think
it's possible yeah I think it's pretty
cool I never wanted to eat it right so I
take a bite and I'm like wow for all the
suffering and all the anguish this
tastes like [ __ ] yeah this tastes so
[ __ ] awful it's extremely boring it
tastes like nothing I just and in my
head I'm like I'm starting to get angry
I'm like this this is what we we kill
these [ __ ] things over just this part
of the fish yeah and we don't use
anything else and we throw it back in
for this and it costs like a million
dollars for a [ __ ] fin what the [ __ ]
we have failed as a society at least
with the giant tortoise there was
records claiming how delicious it was
and how how useful the water sack was
yeah you said we used everything we used
everything in the tortoise what is this
it was [ __ ] and so
God I was just so annoyed the whole
dinner I was just pissed off well I
think it was just like the unfortunate I
didn't know right I don't know I mean it
was it's also like the unfortunate
circumstances that shark fins I mean you
say it tasted like [ __ ] that's fine
because it's like people didn't eat it
for the day so it's like a ceremonial
thing yeah it's like a ceremonial thing
so it starts so [ __ ] it's extremely it's
like Fugu right it's like puffer fish
it's just extremely Bland expensive and
it's purely just to say you've had it
yeah
having having puffer fish it is not
worth the Decades of training you have
to go through as a chef to become a Fugu
chef and I'm like are you seriously
telling me that
and I still have a chance I could die I
just I just think when did we ever be
like you know
Shaman is pretty good eh you did like
when did we have a stray away from the
normal fish who are these [ __ ] who
are making this the hype around this
should I always get this sardines yeah
very good who the [ __ ] pretty good who
the [ __ ] is doing this [ __ ] with the
sharks and the [ __ ] puff officially
just give me a [ __ ] Fried Chicken
okay
oh [ __ ] I'm so angry yeah someone
someone was like you know what
the soul and pepper ain't doing it for
me I need a new spice paprika no give me
danger or give me suffering that is the
best yes you literally pay out the ash
just for danger yeah that's literally it
yeah just just honestly probably eating
like a whole Domino's Pizza is more
danger to your life than the food ever
was you know what I mean like the
cholesterol risk is probably way higher
yeah and then it did it and it didn't
take the pizza chef ten years
I I just don't like as human beings
we're just so [ __ ] weird and why are
we obsessed with this [ __ ] I just don't
get it yeah like I would I wouldn't have
a problem with eating like a weird part
of an animal if you've also used the
rest of this rule if it wasn't cruel you
know if it was killed humanely and stuff
like that and you know if we actually
make use of the animal yeah and that's
why like you know I like how like the
Japanese use like you know animals like
cows or like chickens or like fish for
example of every single part of the app
yeah right we don't let anything go I
realize the irony
[Music]
I'll eat everything I just won't be
happy about it a lot of the time all
right yeah for sure and I'm firmly of
the mindset of like I I'm willing to
kill every animal I I'm willing to eat
yeah yeah same here but also it's
interesting because the whole the
cultural differences right of the
animals that they're willing to eat of
course yeah horse very uncomfortable to
talk about because people don't like
talking about how the fact that Jen uh
Japan Japan is for a horse why are you
going to do Jam like that it's available
a normal [ __ ] bar and you just
there's like horse Sashimi that you can
get as well
like dedicated to horse yeah yeah yeah
very odd and that's a very that's one
that I find that when I mentioned it on
like streamers people have really tough
time getting over that one yeah yes yeah
yeah when you hear like shopping that's
the silly thing that other people do in
other countries
[Music]
again we've spoken about this before
it's all branding horses are cute that's
why we get sad about it and sharks were
cute you'd feel sorry I think Sean's
cute
a lot of people don't show us can be
pretty cool I mean as long you know it's
they also have bad PR you know [ __ ]
Jaws
sports like Jaws bought sharp PR like
through the [ __ ] dirt man yo if if
sharks could sue yo [ __ ] Steven
Spielberg better be like sweating man he
ruined shark images for decades no
centuries even yours does not represent
us
how dare you this is a stereotype I will
not stand for this there's actually a
good question well obviously chickens
are farmed in like giant things like
yeah I I get that all right at least I'm
not [ __ ] throwing it back in the
water and drowning it after I take its
feet yeah yeah exactly
yeah I mean at the end of the day right
it's like it's always it's hard to
police that [ __ ] because it's like oh
people always throw out like that yeah
the culture you know play card you know
being like what we've been eating you
can be as picky as you want with this
and go down any step you'll be like well
you threw away some fries you're so
wasteful you know [ __ ] you yeah I hate
you it's like where do you draw the line
then in terms of like trying like
animals you know I I all I know is that
you shouldn't [ __ ] chop a part of the
animal off and throw back in the water
and let it die then we can all agree on
that yeah it's like it's like if I'm
gonna eat an animal I want to eat and
and I want them to utilize the most as
much of it as much of the animal as
possible so that like there is little to
no waste and no suffering and no
suffering you know if you want to go
deep into that rabbit hole you can go
really deep and it's and you know the
hot stuff you can see online is horrible
yeah
um and that's how vegetarians and vegans
also I want to sleep at night so yeah